>> WELL THERE’S BEEN A MAJOR
REVERSAL AT THE PENTAGON.
THAT AFTER THERE WAS OUTRAGE
OVER A PHYSICIAN TO OFFER COVID
VACCINATIONS TO THE DETAINEES
HELD AT BAY AND THOSE PROTECTED
WHEN SO MANY AMERICANS ARE NOT
ALLEGE MASTERMIND OF THE 9/11
TERRORIST KHALID SHEIKH MUHAMMAD
AND D.O.D. SAYING TO GET
DETAINEES ELIGIBLE FOR SHOTS
NEXT WEEK TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF FEDERAL PROSECUTORS WHO WERE
TRYING THE TERRORISM CASES
AGAINST THOSE INMATES.
WELL PENTAGON SPOKESMAN SAYS
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT IS PUTTING A
PAUSE ON THAT PLAN.
CARRIES OUT REVIEW OF PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS HERE’S FORMER NEW YORK
CITY FIRE COMMISSIONER THOMAS
WHO HELD THAT JOB ON 9/11
REACTING TO THE INITIAL
DECISION.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE’VE GOT HUNDRED THOUSANDS,
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT DON’T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE
SHOT AND WE’RE WORRYING ABOUT
CRIMINALS THAT WE SPEND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS YEAR TO TAKE CARE OF.
BUT THESE 40 LOW LIVES DIDN’T
GET THE VACCINE, WOULDN’T BOTHER
ME AT ALL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE’LL STAY ON TOP OF THIS